what a weird time we're living in I just
hope all this Trump stuff doesn't make
it even harder in the future for men to
become president Poorman for men you
guys have had a rough couple weeks I
love men one of my best friends is a man
I am actually half man on my dad's side
yeah I get it you know it's a rough time
but lately I've developed a very
rational fear of men based on how you
portray yourselves in person like if I'm
walking down the street and I see a
group of businessmen I don't know what
the term is like a fraud if I just if I
see a scam of men and suits coming
towards me I'll find that I'll just
instinctively clutch my purse and be
like don't groped me don't grope me I'm
awake
a lot of my a lot of my male friends are
really nervous in this whole me too
moment so they're asking me for advice
and I tell them if you're around a woman
and she makes you feel nervous just
picture her clothes
thank of her as your daughter or better
yet a person treat her as an equal I
know it sounds crazy but then maybe she
won't blog about you on a website no
one's ever heard of babe gov thanks
Conan it's um it's a tough time for men
right now it's also a tough time for
women or if there are any Republicans
watching by women I just mean wounds
yeah it's a tough time for men it's also
tough time for us wombs it's a tough
time for everybody really well except
Nazis Thank You Nazis they're having a
great year you know they're getting
glossy write-ups in The Lying New York
Times polling well with Republicans
they're really just killing it you know
you can tell how far we've slipped as a
country in just the past year by how
it's no longer okay to joke about Nazis
it's no longer kosher to joke about
Nazis everybody is so sensitive right
now they're like don't joke about Nazis
my neighbors are Nazi
we didn't know that a year ago but now
some of our neighbors are Nazis like I
feel bad for World War two vets who
couldn't talk politics at the
Thanksgiving table because their
grandkids are Nazis it's like grandpa
don't talk about liberating Auschwitz
you'll upset Trevor
[Applause]
any notches you're laughing but I have
to ask there in America we all saw the
footage of Charlotte's ville guys
dressed like dads who lost custody of
their kids prancing around a college
campus they couldn't get into exercising
free speech with their ar-15 you know
like nothing David Duke was there he's
very hard to spot with all the plastic
surgery he's had you'd think for a white
supremacist he'd be more comfortable in
his own skin
thank you one guy thank you our country
is very divided right now about what to
do with this new strain of North
American Teke Nazi do we punch them do
we not punch them you know it's tough
because it's like on one hand violence
incites violence but so do not see so
what do we do I don't think violence is
ever the answer but I do think we need
to do a better job at making Nazis feel
less safe to be Nazis in America and
espouse their ideology and recruit other
Nazis because that doesn't really ever
work out for anyone who's not a Nazi or
for Nazis thank you
it doesn't work out for Nazis either
like it's not like they won you know so
here's my advice if you see a Nazi on
the street don't punch him but maybe
lightly harass him cat call him tell him
to smile if any Nazis work for you
pay them less take credit for their
ideas except that one you guys see where
this is going
if we in America treat Nazis the way
that we treat women at the very least
they will never become president
[Applause]
you